hello everyone and thank you for tuning
in for our cloud on-air sessions today
we have three sessions and I have the
honor to do the first one about cloud
spanner after me will be a session about
storage Google Cloud storage and then
thereafter about G suite hardening
security hardening
I'm Robert Kubis I'm a cloud developer
advocate on the Google cloud platform we
understand our job as like a
bi-directional job between the
developers that build on the Google
cloud platform and the developers had
built the platform for you what are we
going to talk today about today I gonna
do an introduction on Google cloud
spanner so I will start off with what
cloud spanner is and where it comes from
I gonna talk about how it works like
behind the scenes I gonna give you an in
like a small demo like how you can get
started and Google cloud platform and on
cloud spanner and at the end I gonna
talk a little bit about some use cases
and industries and verticals work you
can use clouds better alright so let's
get started so what is cloud spanner
imagine the scenario is that you have an
application that grows over time it gets
viral and like a lot of people are using
it and this system is backed by a
relational database right so for
instance you have billing data or any
kinds of things like payments and things
like that at some point like you would
need to scale your database to like cope
with the traffic that you're getting so
you have two options you basically look
at either scaling up your relational
database but this has a sitting right
like you basically have to wait for your
cloud provider to provide a bigger
machine or for your hardware vendor to
provide a bigger machine and then you
have to move everything over very very
complicated the other option is that if
you can outgrow your your vertical
scalable solution you are looking at
other solutions which are scaling
horizontal so you're looking at usually
at no SQL databases where you scale
horizontally but by scaling horizontally
and going to the no SQL way you're
giving up some really really nice
features of our two relational databases
so in between these two you do you have
some
thing that is called charting where you
can chart a relational database but you
give up a lot of the qualities as well
for the relational database and it gets
really really complicated so we actually
were faced with exactly that problem
here in Google our ads business was
running on a shorted MySQL and we needed
to find a solution which enables us to
scale as at the rate we were scaling and
growing the company without having
interruption without taking down the
entire database you can imagine like
Google is a 24/7 business and we cannot
afford like basically taking our system
offline for maintenance for schema
upgrades or for migrating from one
system to another so after like we had
like our system like charted for for
many many years and like the last chart
took two years we built actually a new
system which were giving us these
attributes that we were looking for a
system that can scale horizontally is
slowly distributed and strongly
consistent so please meet a cloud
spanner cloud spanner is actually this
system that we are using inside of
Google so a cloud spanner we have used
for for many many years inside of Google
and we now make it available as a
product as a fully managed product under
the Google cloud platform umbrella so
just to recap what are the features of
Google cloud spanner it is an enterprise
create database it is globally
distributed it is strongly consistent we
don't sacrifice anything there and
you've been you combine the benefits of
a relational database with the
horizontal scale so you get a lot of the
features that you're familiar with from
a traditional relational database so
things like asset transactions things
like is the structured query language
and you get also an SLA from us that is
up to five nines of uptime so this is
about 23 seconds per months that we
allow us at downtime so many a question
that we get asked is like how does
Google Cloud spanner compare to
either traditional databases traditional
relational databases or to like the more
new or modern one that non-relational
note so-called new SQL databases so you
can see a table where we compare a
couple of the attributes of these two
databases and I want to start with
relational database as we saw in the
first scenario like in a relational
database you basically you can only
scale vertically right you can add like
main memory can add disk and you can add
CPU but at some point you reach a
ceiling scalability to your ceiling and
if you want to stay relational what you
have to do is basically chart your
relational database so you basically say
ok I gonna have like part of this table
there part of this table on a second
database and then you pull out all these
nice features from a relational database
like asset transactions and referential
constraints and you have to re-implement
these things in your application so it's
a lot of a lot of things that you have
to take deal with and it's a lot of like
operational overhead so basically if you
look at a relational database system
it's not really scalable in a sense
right it's really difficult to scale now
a lot of companies they went like ok
scalability is something I cannot
sacrifice on I need a scalable database
so they went the no SQL way no SQL has a
lot of nice things you have like more
structure flexibility in your schemas
and you can actually distribute it under
like to many many nodes and horizontal
scaling but none of these traditional no
SQL databases has actually like your
strong consistency across multiple
regions and is still usable in the sense
of like that is that it has low latency
of course they a database is no SQL
databases where you can tweak the
consistency model and can decide how
much to insistency you want to have for
your queries but still it's really
really complicated and usually where it
gets very slow if you want to have a
very strong consistency for your new SQL
databases now the other thing is like
replication for for the tradition
database system you can replicate to to
multiple instances and then use these
instances for incidents for like are we
the only replicas by that freeing up
your master node from some read
performance that it usually uses up and
then can actually use more writes or do
more writes on on these on your master
node alright so how does cloud spanner
actually work I want to start with like
a logical architecture overview about
cloud spanner so you start with cloud
spanner with an instance so an instance
is basically your resource pool your
compute nodes and your storage and in
this instance you can create databases
so you can grade I think about thousand
twenty-four databases and then about two
thousand tables in each of your database
all these databases and tables live in
this instance so this is your resource
pool and you can create multiple
databases now this is something that
you're familiar with from a relational
database now there is another structure
which is somewhat hidden from you but we
talked about it and that is actually
splits so splits are basically where we
take a table and order it by your
primary key alphabetically or
lexicographically and then we take
ranges of your table and split it by
ranges and that enables a really really
cool thing in cloud spanner so what are
we doing with this so as mentioned you
get with an instance a resource pool off
of compute node and storage now what we
can do is basically we replicate all
this in multiple zones and by that get a
high high availability and also some
scalability in terms of really we can
perform now to get like high like high
is read and write throughput we actually
use the splits and distribute them
across like the computes that are
available and by that we have multiple
computes basically being able to manage
your reads and writes so what we have
here you can see as we separate the
compute and storage we have three zones
so this is a schematic for a regional
instance now in my regional instance
here I choose three nodes so I have
three nodes replicated through all three
zones so in total we get nine compute
nodes now what is really important for
these splits so these like parts of your
table these ranges is that there's
exactly and never more than one compute
node responsible for a split and we do
this by using Texas so we use basically
here in this example I have to split one
I have in each so in one compute node
who's responsible for that split one and
then from these three nodes that are
responsible from four split one I need
to pick a leader so in here in this case
we use actually paksas which is a
consensus algorithm to choose a leader
in this group but as I mentioned it's
really really important that we never
have two leaders for a split so how do
we do that actually performant Lee and
that's where true time is coming in so
you see unlike to time is something that
we invented inside Google to be able to
have something like a global wall clock
time so let me talk a little bit more
about through time so true time is
basically what we do all over the world
globally in our data centers we have GPS
and atomic clocks and what we need
actually is we need something that we
can trust all around the world so let me
give you an example imagine you have
your friend with you and you compare
watches and you synchronize these
watches and then you went off and you
meet again after a week or let's say a
month your watches will have drifted
let's assume it's not as much what
SmartWatch that there are resynchronize
it by itself let's have one of these old
analog watches right so they will drift
from each other and this drift is
actually dangerous in the sense of like
if I trust these locks I have actually
two different times in two different
places and by that I could have two
leaders for split and get inconsistency
so we needed something that we actually
can trust all around the world so we
invented through time which gives you
actually not a specific time but it
gives you a range of time it gives you
an upper and a lower bound for a time
that is either pass or not pass all
around the world so let
me be a little bit more concrete here so
true time basically quantifies the worst
possible error drift between data
centers you get a lower bound that lower
by an defines that this time stem has
passed all over the world and you get an
upper bound which is a time stem that
has passed nowhere in the world
now with these two times them so you can
actually make sure that you have never
more than one leader or split which is
really really cool
so to synchronize actually our atomic
clocks we use GPS time masters in our in
our data centers these are synchronizing
our atomic clocks and then these atomic
clocks basically when we get a true time
for for spanner but also other use cases
in the Google cloud platform we ask a
subset of time master so the GPS time
masters an atomic clocks and then if
there's any outlier we just say like
okay this is a bad time master we don't
trust it we take it out but basically
since we have a subset of this time
master we basically take them and draw
it here of that now in the normal
operation these atomic clocks drift by
about 50 microseconds per second or two
and a mega seconds per second and we
resynchronizing about 30 every 30
seconds now some of you might ask like
what happens if like all our time
masters go down in the data center now
we can actually ask to time times them
from a different data center and we just
calculate in the latency it takes to
travel to this other data center and get
the to time times them what that means
is the epsilon so the range between the
upper and lower bound gets bigger and by
that the database will actually slow
down but it will not stop it will still
be operational all right so what is the
data format in Google Cloud spanner so
the the data format is actually what
you're very familiar with we are using
for Google Cloud spanner SQL MZ 2011
with a couple of extensions so you can
use just the normal DD LS you are
familiar with from a traditional
relational database and create your
schemas so here in this example I have a
single stable
and an album table and I just create
that with strongly types string or
integer and things like that define
primary keys now there is a feature
since this is a distributed database
there are a couple of things that are
not available in Google Cloud spanner
compared to a traditional database
system things like a referential
constraints but we have something that
where you can optimize your access
patterns and that is something that we
call interleaving so this is a technique
to basically physically interleave child
tables into parent tables by that you
gain data locality so you can actually
group data together and make sure that
queries if you do joins a lot on like
the parent table and the child table
that these queries can be answered by
one node or only up set of nodes all
right so how does it look like how can
you actually create interleave data
tables here in this example we have like
our singer's table that we saw from the
example before and then we have the
album's table and you just say like
interleave in fingers what's really
important here is that you share the
primary key of your parent table that is
really important so that the
interleaving actually works I want to
tell you that be a little bit careful
with this interleaving means like that
all the data in your parent table and
child table end up in one split we
talked about split pls earlier one split
is managed by one compute node so if you
have one row in your in your parent
table all the stuff like all the data
from your from your interleaf table that
qualifies for this primary key ends up
in the same split so if you have a large
side table onto one row of your parent
table you might run into limits off like
we'd write capacity and also storage
capacity so be a little bit careful
there especially also for scalability
reasons a really really cool feature
about cloud spanner which was really
important for us when we adopted it
inside of Google was that we have no
down time schema changes so what you can
do with Google nodes better you can
actually alter your table at tables add
indexes without any any downtime and
you're going to show that in a second as
well
all right so how can you actually get
started with Google ads banner so your
first stop will be cloud that google.com
slash spanner so this is our entry page
or page where you can go in and learn
about cloud spanner you have links to
the docs but you find also a lot of the
things that I just talked about like
comparison between the out spanner and
traditional databases as well as no no
SQL databases we talked about use cases
and you find all the way to the bottom
also some use cases and like studies
around like Google Cloud spanner so I
really can recommend to read the Quizlet
blog when if you're coming from a
charted MySQL database you want to know
how Quizlet did the D charting into
cloud spanner this is a really good blog
post very technical alright so you get
started in the Google cloud platform
console so consult google.com sold out
loud at google.com and there this is the
home screen that you see here now you
have multiple options to go to cloud
spanner you either use the search box in
the top you can actually go to the
search tool bar by hitting slash as you
might be familiar from from them but you
can also use the hamburger symbol here
in the left upper corner and then go to
spanner you find it somewhere in our
drawer you go to spanner and there it is
I have already one instance created I
can talk about in a second but let's
create an instance first so you click on
create instance you give it a name you
say cloud and air it fills in the
instance ID automatically you can change
it if you want then you have the the
opportunity to choose between a regional
or multi-regional instance so regional
is basically a sloughed spanner instance
this will across three zones in one
region multi-regional gives you the
opportunity to distribute your cloud
spanner instance across multiple regions
up to a global configuration where you
have the readwrite replicas in in
the US and then you have read-only
replicas for instance in Europe and and
in Asia
all right so we gonna choose and use us
central one here you see also on the
right side what US central one
configuration is like all the API names
replicas how many replicas you get our
SLA for a regional instance it is four
nines of SLA and to be qualified for the
s8 you need to at least have three notes
writing so I gonna do three notes here
you're gonna see like what the cost is
per hour for the notes and then also the
storage cost you create a click create
and within seconds literally you get
your own instance now you can start it
started and create your database here
and create a schema and everything but I
don't want to show you how to do this
programmatically so let's switch over to
my IntelliJ instance and I gonna show
you how to get started so I choose for
this session to show you the Java client
so to get started with the Java client
you have to like either use Gradle or
maven in this case I use maven pump file
and you basically select the Google
Cloud spanner client library for Java
currently in version 0.34 Co beta you
have to import also the Google library
and then the Google authentication to
authenticate against cloudspinner so
it's actually very simple to to get
authenticated if you run your client on
a GC instance or from from your laptop
which is set up with G cloud which is
our SDK which comes with a CLI and
everything you can actually use the
authentication context of either your
GCE instance or your laptop that is
already authenticated so I'm authentic
ated against my project with my laptop
and to use the authentication there I
just do guru doctored and get
applications default one line all right
I capture some exceptions here but
basically is one line your authenticated
great so next thing that I need is I
need the instance in my project that I
want to talk to and the database that I
want to talk to so here in this case I
talked about spanner cloud and yeah the
instance that I just created and I gonna
create a database which with the name
demo so let's jump into create database
so for the great database we basically
have to get a database admin client so
we get that from our spanner library get
the database admin client and we say
like which what is the instance ID I
filled that into this function and I
want to also know the database ID so
what you see here is I actually create a
database in that instance with the I so
in my spanner iCloud on-air instance
with the database name demo and then I
define the DDL here so the schema and I
recommend everybody like if the first
schema that you create with your
database created right away with your
data with your database if you create it
after your database it will take a while
schema changes are not as fast as like
queries and things like that so they can
take up to minutes and depending on if
you create indexes that needs to be back
back fold it can take hours or days
alright so here in my case I creating an
account table with three columns account
ID name and email and I create an
address table and I interleave all of
this so with this interleaving I do the
colocation and also have that one
feature that I actually can do a delete
cascade so if I delete the parent row I
actually can make sure that all the
addresses in my address table for that
parent or are deleted as well so let me
run this this should take only a couple
seconds now the setup of the client
takes a couple of seconds so this is not
like coming back right away but you see
down here that it actually finished so
we can go back and check if our instance
actually was created and we see we have
our demo database all right very cool so
now is this demo database I can do
things like we I can see the schema you
see down here that I show it the schema
I see my indexes I can run queries I
kind of show us
and I can inspect this query see like we
planned see like where's time spend
optimized my queries things like that I
also have features in the console that
where you can actually directly add data
in your in in the console in the cloud
console so if you want to insert data
edit data or delete data you have the
possibility to do that directly from the
console especially good if you do some
testing things like that all right so we
have created the database so let's go
back to our Java program and the first
thing that I gonna do I insert some data
so let's go to the insert what you can
see here is we are creating a list of
mutations so mutations are basically
very group any kinds of changes for the
database together so in this case I
building actually insert mutations where
insert a bunch of data into my account
table as well as in my address table I
want to point out one thing I'm using
here a idea and which I declared a
string 32 and that's nothing else and I
use a UID version 4 and then convert it
to a hex and by that I basically have a
string of 32 right so why do I use UID
in a distributed database you don't want
to use something that is monotonically
increasing or decreasing the reason is
that we split the tables by ranges like
primary key and if you have something
that is monotonically increasing or
decreasing you always end up in the
first or in the last bit by that
overloading the node that is responsible
for that spin so if you want to get the
best out of your instance the best out
of cloud spanner you want to distribute
your load as as best as possible so
that's why I'm using a UID as a primary
key here so let's run this and we're
gonna go back and see if this data was
actually created so now in my address
table I should be able to go to data and
you see that I have some data ok great
the next thing that I want to do is I
want to do a read-only so in my
read-only what I do is I create actually
read only query
this doesn't create any locks in this
case I'm just selecting the name and an
email from my account data and and check
where like the country is in Germany so
let's see if I actually have some data
in there that is from Germany so let me
run this really to point out here it is
important is that this like do you
declare a single use read-only
transaction by that we know that this
can be locked free so we don't need to
acquire any locks as you can see down
here I have two users in my database
that are living in Germany all right the
next thing that I want to show is a read
white transaction so in a readwrite
transaction this is a little bit more
complicated so in our cloud and spanner
client in the Java library client what
we provide is actually the rerunning of
transactions if they fail and we do this
by providing a runnable a transaction
runnable so to say so what we do here is
we creating a readwrite transaction and
we provided a transaction runner and in
this transaction runner I do my
transaction so what I'm doing here is
I'm executing I'm running a select
statement checking for all accounts that
have my email address and then updating
the name in that account and then I
bubble this together and send it to the
transaction so if I run this this should
change my data we can change it have a
look at the account if there is anything
changed - esperen guru and as you can
see here we have the name change to
Spyder guru all right so I one node to
the to the mutations mutations are
important to know about beakers like
there's a limit in cloud spanner so a
cloud spanner has a limit of 20,000
mutations per transaction but what is a
mutation in this context of the 20000
limit mutation is actually any change on
a cell level in cloud spanner so as an
example if I have a table with five
columns and I insert a row in this table
then I have five mutations now if I
define an index on that table which
indices and
or let's say another two rows then and I
insert a row into into my table then
it's actually eight mutations right so a
be aware of that if you see the limit of
like you reach twenty case hours in
mutations per transaction that this is
not twenty thousand rows it is actually
rows multiplied by how many columns in
the row plus in indices that you have
all right last but not least I gonna
clean up but I'm gonna do that later all
right one thing that I wanted to show
you really quick is I have actually a
example database here and that example
database does not it's like it's
imitating like a ticket sales platform
imagine like a global ticket sale a
seller who sells tickets to like events
all over the world we did this test with
a database of 80 terabytes of data so
something that wouldn't fit in a
traditional database and we did that
test also with transactions to limit
that wouldn't fit in a traditional
database now I have a little smaller one
here but I want to show you this is a
query to get actually seat availability
of all events that are happening today
from 9 a.m. in this cloud session
started the cloud entire session started
to tomorrow at 5 a.m. right so and then
I'm looking for all the events that are
happening and I'm also checking like how
many seats are available and how many
seats are available in total and things
like that so what is remarkable about
this about this query you don't have to
think about charting or anything this is
just really how you would see it in a
traditional database no specialties
about charting or things like that
distribution this is all handled for you
and you can also hear right here in the
console get an explanation of you create
see the query plan see like how many
rows were skinned how much time were
spent and you can optimize security with
this information so it's really really
powerful all right so the last couple of
minutes lets me talk a little bit about
use cases in these industries and
verticals so where does cloud spent to
help meet business goals there are three
things that are really important to
mention here
so one thing as we saw cloud spanner
uses traditional tools and thus ends off
what you're familiar with from
traditional databases so it has SQL it
has asset transactions so you don't need
like this logic in your application
layer things like that so you can
actually tap into existing resources
developers that are familiar with
relational database they have a very
easy transition to cloud spanner another
thing is with cloud spanner out of the
box you get performance and scale and
high availability the way that cloud
spanner is set up it is I available and
has two disaster recovery mechanisms
built in you don't have to worry about
that all of this is done by us up to
five nines as we provide that we provide
for that you have regional and
multi-regional instances low latency
transactions and reads and as mentioned
simplified operation fully managed for
you a couple of clicks and you set up
with your own instance that you can
interact with where you can write data
and read data data from so what are a
couple of like business use cases that
you can log into there we look at like
four main categories or themes I want to
talk about it here so the first one is
like transactional consistency over
database that is growing a lot so
imagine like you have a supply chain
management or like an e-commerce
platform and you have a lot of data that
you put in your database so you outgrow
basically on the storage side your
traditional database systems now what
you can do is we talked about the
starting or go Noella but you lose the
transaction consistency or have it
really really difficult and have to
build it into your application which is
very out prone the second one is a scale
for reads and writes so imagine like you
have a telecom or billing gaming company
it does like all kind of actions which
are happening on your gaming platform or
for instance for a telecom company like
all kinds of calls that are going on
need to go into a transactional system
now usually where
top out on is like the reads and writes
that you can do on your relational
database spinner the way it is set up
scales horizontally 40 reads and writes
so you get strong consistency and scale
for reads and writes for that another
use case that we see of theme is a
global data just imagine you have
something where you want to have the
data all over the world
you are globally a company and you want
to have access to your data from all
over the world and again you want to
have a consistent view on this imagine
like financial services like banks that
are operating globally or insurances or
global call centers that need actually a
few which is consistent all over the
world and the third one is database
consolidation just think like logistic
or manufacturing where you have the
supply chain again and you want to
consolidate the data from multiple data
sources into one database again to have
a strong consistent view on this but
also the ease of use because you have
only one system that you have to manage
and to deal with for for your data and
your applications alright I want to
close out with a little bit step out and
do an overview of like where clouds
benefits in in the Google cloud database
portfolio so I talked about cloud
spanner and all the goodies that clouds
may not come with but we understand that
there are other use cases where our
databases are more suitable so if you
look on the left you have like our App
Engine memcache which is good for like
mobile development and epitaphs things
like that we have our relational where
we talked about loud spanner just now
and we have cloud SQL which is a
traditional database system in the
flavors of MySQL or Postgres where you
can scale vertically it is managed again
you manage for your read replicas and we
can also do muscle mass or application
this is good for applications where you
are good with a vertical scalable system
and maybe you transition on my creative
system which was running before on a
MySQL Postgres we have also our
non-relational famers flavors so you can
look at cloud datastore which is a
document based
database it's very scalable big
companies that are well known around the
world have built on cloud datastore and
have scaled from a couple users to
millions hundreds of millions of users
on cloud datastore we have cloud big
table which is backing or our search
like for very fast reads and writes you
can use cloud BigTable is a row based
database so you have transactions on row
level but not across road level and then
we have cloud storage which are is for
our flop storage so this a with cloud
storage we have different tiers for
based on like how often you access the
data you can save some money on there
or this really cool cloud storage is
also backed by cloud spanner so if you
do an LS unplowed storage in the US and
that's it and and in Europe you always
get the same view so all data that you
commit to cloud storage be it a video
file or any any other file you will get
a consistent view on the data that is in
cloud storage and last but not least
really really an amazing product is our
bigquery product which is our OLAP so
data warehouse product where you can
load terabytes and petabytes of data
into bigquery and query it in minutes or
seconds or minutes actually like very
very powerful where it like very
powerful query language you have UDF's
in bigquery that you can use so please
try it out if you want to do any data
analytics I have a look at bigquery and
with this I want to close for for a
second we're gonna switch into the Q&A
session after we regroup a little bit so
please stay tuned we will get back with
the questions that you ask so they have
on the right side you should see some
the Q&A platform where you're able to
actually put questions in and we're
gonna answer a couple of those in a
minute thank you very much
all right hello back we got a couple of
really cool questions from the audience
so I gonna go through them you should
see them on the screen and I gonna go
through them one by one but the first
question that we have is what's the
difference between MySQL or Postgres or
other relational databases and spanner
so if you look at traditional database a
relational database like MySQL posters
or any of the big vendor databases they
are like by default a vertical scalable
system cloud spanner on the other hand
is a horizontally scalable this system
without giving any any of the dice
criterias up from a relational database
so we have strong consistency we have
asset transactions in spanner but we are
horizontally scalable so you can load
terabytes hundreds of terabytes of data
into our database you can have millions
of reads and writes with cloud spanner
so that is the main difference from
cloud spanner in my scalp the second
question was is it possible to migrate
from current SQL systems like MySQL to
cloud spanner it is definitely possible
to migrate but I have to say like this
is not a lift and shift migration so
because cloud spanner is a distributed
system there are some things to take
like to be aware of and that need to be
considered when migrating from a MySQL
system so one of the things is we are
currently not supporting you to UDF so
user defined functions triggers were
stored procedures on cloud spanner so if
you use any of this you need to like we
implement these things in an application
layer but you get all the scalability
and the transaction allowed spanner
other than that you can currently
microwave from SQL systems by using our
client libraries so you export from your
existing database and then create a
schema modify the schema to be suitable
for the distributed system and then load
your data into cloud spanner and run it
there
the third question was why not just use
a new SQL database one thing consistency
so if you look at normal like
traditional no SQL databases then
the first thing that you give up is
consistency most of the know SQL
databases to achieve the scalability and
the high availability they are giving up
strong consistency so many of these
systems are eventually consistent and
what that means is as an example you
have the World Cup and the World Cup is
published to a database and somebody
goes onto a website and checks the score
of the World Cup and sees okay that has
finished and this country won the World
Cup and then the friend that is sitting
next to you you tell them like hey like
this country won the World Cup and the
friend is going to the website but he's
going to a different replica of your of
your new SQL database and for him that
day the game hasn't finished all right
so the data hasn't replicated to all
replicas and so two people can see
different results in cloud spanner this
cannot happen if the data has been
committed all replicas have that data
and so if any requests are coming in
from all over the world everybody will
see exactly the same data the fourth
question is does cloudspinner have
client libraries yes we do have client
libraries we have client libraries for
nodejs Java PHP go and Python and we are
working on a lot of other ones we have
also C sharp we even have the C sharp or
M connector re available and the fifth
question was the sloughed spanner
encrypt by a data so cloud spanner all
the data in flight and at the rest is
encrypted on cloud spanner so if you
load any of your data in there at rest
all the data is encrypted now if you
want to have encryption on top of des
that you need to put this encryption on
top of that why are we talking about
encrypting data I want to talk about
like the permissions that you can set on
on cloud spanner so we have identity and
access management system and Google
cloud platform we call it I am and you
can actually set I M rolls up to the
database level who's allowed to access
your database read write and execute
queries things like that all right
see if you have some other
okay cool I think that's all the
questions that we had do we have any
other questions I see there are a couple
of other questions should we answer them
or should we okay we like we're gonna
answer actually the other questions
offline we're gonna undo them so please
stay tuned if you have asked any other
questions we're gonna definitely answer
them after this session the next session
will come out of our Kirkland office in
Seattle and QL toplin is talking about
the right storage class to optimize the
performance of your workload so please
stay tuned for the next session out of
Seattle thank you very much for your
time and I hope you enjoyed this session